I don't know I don't know why Eat Pray
Love has had the impact that it's had I
also don't know
I mean I've written books before this
you know um and they sold upwards of
dozens of copies you know I don't know
how that happened if I knew how that
happened I would do it again or I would
have been doing it all along you know um
it's it there's a there's a certain
randomness in in the way that my
questions for some reason about my life
intersected dovetailed with questions
that apparently a lot of other people
women in particular at this moment in
history were asking about their lives
one possible answer is I mean I do feel
like I'm a pretty representative example
of my culture you know I'm I'm pretty
representative 21st century middle-aged
American woman in the way that I've been
educated in the way that you know in the
things that I've been led to believe
that my life should feel like in the
disappointments that I experienced when
my life doesn't feel like that the the
particular kinds of questions that that
haunt me at the things that I want and
wonder about you know I don't think I
have any particularly special I think I
feel that stuff the same way that
certainly everybody I know feels those
things you know and again pointing to
the question of privilege because of the
fact that I'm a writer I have and
because of the fact that I've been able
to build a career as a writer and sort
of organize my time in a certain way I
have access to a lot more time than
other people might have to think about
those things I was able to say I'm gonna
take one entire year and do literally
nothing every minute of the day except
think about all these questions I
remember before I left on the trip this
friend of mine who's a mother of two
she's a doctorate she's you know at home
right now with her kids but certainly
has this ferociously intelligent mind
you know she's just sat me down and said
take us with you you know all of us who
are asking these same things but are
staying here you know with our families
with our kids with our work
you know take us with you and and ask
the questions that we would ask and do
the work that we would want to do if we
could you know so I think I felt a great
obligation to do that while I was
traveling in a way I didn't forget that
and and and I would ask myself what
would crease ooze and cat want to know
if they were here and and sort of fill
that in and then try to answer those
questions on the page and I wrote the
book very directly as a letter to one
specific person I wrote the book to my
friend Darcy stanky who's a wonderful
novelist and a memoirist and who was
also on a very different sort of
spiritual path aspera peppered a
different one for me she's a student of
Christianity but is also this hipster
who lives in Brooklyn single mom and and
we've had a long ranging conversation
over the years about marriage about
divinity about autonomy about all these
questions that you know are foremost in
our minds and this book became a kind of
extended letter to her and the one thing
that I've heard people to say when they
read the book or when they respond to it
in this way and certainly not everybody
has responded to it positively by the
way you know but the people who do say I
feel as though we were having a
conversation and I feel so you were
talking directly to me because in a
sense I I was I was talking directly to
one person who is also a very
representative 21st century American
women and and so maybe that's it you
know maybe it just feels like you know
we're knee to knee with like a cup of
coffee between us trying to figure out
this stuff together which maybe we need
right now
yeah well I think that going and
traveling very literally to very literal
places is about as much the opposite of
like the Facebook blogosphere virtual
you know at you know avatars world that
that's so many people live in or at
least that I hear so many people live in
I'm not sure whether people live in that
world quite as much as as commentators
like to imagine that they do I you know
I still feel like people have a lot of
interpretive interpersonal contact and
communication with each other in really
real ways although there's nothing like
actually going to Naples and eating a
pizza you know um to make you feel like
you're really in a place doing a thing
but I don't think that I'm not sure that
the dream of pilgrimage is new you know
I think it's hardwired into us in some
way the yearning to to step aside from
the fold and the clan and go off into
the desert the mountain the cave the
holy city the you know whatever you know
whatever the this sort of dream of
distance is that's something that is
part of every single human society on
earth and I think the way I did it was
just a way that was reflective of you
know the kind of person that I am and
the kind of culture that I grew up in
and and the kind of stuff that I was
yearning for and wanting but you know I
always find it really interesting you
know you go back and you read these
accounts in Roman histories of people
going to India you know like being sent
to India from by Indian emperors or
sorry by Roman emperors people being
sent to India to specifically find these
Yogi's that everybody was talking about
and see if they could get an audience
with them and see if they could study
them and then they would come back to
Rome and they would report you know
they're these guys who you know go into
these states where their hearts stopped
beating and claim to you know understand
that the makings of the world and and
you know as people were sort of
discussing that then and longing for
that then so I just think the idea of
going on a holy journey
is is something that not all of us but
damn a whole lot of us dream about you
know at some point I I just can't tell
you how many people have sort of
confessed that to me as though it's some
dirty hidden secret when in fact I think
it's it's almost like a linkage of